hello who is this
my name is Richard Lee and I'm running
for city council so I just wanted to
introduce myself
excuse me
my name is Richard Lee and I'm running
for city council I just want to say
hello hello are you a Democrat
s yeah
then leave
thank you are you a Democrat hey what
was the giveaway I think it was when he
walked up to the doors
[Music]
uh come again what was that it's like
the teacher in Charlie Brown
this was the only silver lining the
storm cloud of the mass
is that when when the libs made us all
wear the masks and the conservatives
didn't do it or if we did we had it
below our nose and we did a very very
grudgingly in certain cases it just lets
you know who's who